[Música]
la muerte de seis reos en una cárcel de
Guayaquil vuelve a evidenciar la crisis
penitenciaria por la que atraviesa el
país estos precios aparecieron ahorcados
en una zona del penal controlada por una
banda criminal
el presidente brasileño Luis Ignacio
Lola da Silva llegó a China para una
visita oficial Buscar nuevas inversiones
En la nación suramericana y también la
guerra en Ucrania son algunos de los
temas a tratar
el expresidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump demandó a su ex abogado Michael
cohen El Magnate acusa al que fuera uno
de sus aliados más cercanos de no haber
cumplido con el acuerdo de
confidencialidad cohen es el testigo
estrella en el caso de corrupción por el
que Trump fue imputado
Sean bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
informativa aquí en la pantalla de
France 24 Estas son las noticias más
destacadas del continente americano Yo
soy Juan pupiales en Ecuador se expresos
fueron encontrados ahorcados en una
cárcel de la ciudad de Guayaquil hace un
enfermaron autoridades locales según el
reporte del hallazgo de los cuerpos tuvo
lugar durante la revisión en uno de los
pabellones de la penitenciaría del
litoral cada uno de los cuerpos se
encontraba en su respectiva celda en un
área del penal que internamente es
controlado por la banda delictiva las
águilas el presidente ecuatoriano
Guillermo lasso Indicó que las recientes
muertes en cárceles en la ciudad de
Guayaquil corresponden a disputas entre
grupos delincuenciales
yo me levanto y encuentro la noticia que
hay seis muertos en el pabellón 5 y mi
hermano está en el pabellón cinco y
Queremos saber que nos den información
si en la lista del listado de esos seis
muertos que hay seis muertos y ahorita
ya dicen ocho muertos no se sabe muy
bien cómo es la cosa allá adentro y yo
quiero saber si mi como mi hijo está en
el pabellón cinco que desde que me
ingresaron yo no lo veo a mi hijo no lo
veo no lo veo lo adelantábamos en
titulares con la búsqueda de inversiones
y la guerra en Ucrania Como algunos de
los principales temas el presidente de
Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva llegó
a China para una visita oficial El
mandatario arribó este miércoles a
Shanghai y se quedará hasta en el país
hasta el sábado Lula me ha insistido en
que Brasil y China Medellín una posible
negociación entre Ucrania y Rusia el
segundo gran tema que tratarán es la
cooperación económica y tecnológica
entre los gigantes de Sudamérica y Asia
Brasil es el país con mayor inversión
china en América Latina especial tema
especialmente en temas de Electricidad y
de petróleo el gobierno de Lula espera
cerrar más de 20 acuerdos bilaterales
entre las dos naciones
este miércoles falleció la ministra de
Educación universitaria de Venezuela
tibisa y lucena Quien fuera la
presidente del Consejo Nacional
electoral durante 14 años la
vicepresidenta del cierre Rodríguez dio
la noticia de la muerte pero no explicó
Cuáles fueron las causas desde Caracas
nuestra corresponsal Daniela Zambrano
nos cuenta quién era tibisa y lucena
fue una figura muy controversial en
Venezuela se le atribuye haberle dado el
soporte institucional a los gobiernos de
Hugo Chávez y Nicolás Maduro para su
permanencia en el poder a través del
voto esto mediante cuestionados comicios
presidenciales estuvo al frente del
Consejo Nacional electoral en la
presidencia durante 14 años desde el año
2006 hasta el año 2020 y bajo su gestión
fueron denunciadas múltiples
irregularidades como en el registro
electoral permanente la migración de
votantes la modificación de circuitos
electorales todo esto estrategias que
según sus detractores favorecían al
partido de gobierno en el 2018 estaba al
frente de los cuestionados comicios
presi en los que resultó electo Nicolás
maduro y que fueron desconocidos por
gran parte de la comunidad internacional
a su salida del cne fue nombrada rectora
de la universidad experimental de las
artes y en el año 2021 pasó a formar
parte del gabinete de Nicolás maduro
como ministra de Educación Universitaria
un cargo por el que también fue
cuestionada y lucena fue sancionada por
Estados Unidos la Unión Europea y Canadá
tras ser señalada de que mediante
acciones emprendidas Bajo su cargo en el
Consejo Nacional electoral haber
socavado la democracia en Venezuela y el
estado de derecho su muerte fue
anunciada por la vicepresidenta delsi
Rodríguez a través de las redes sociales
no ofreció mayores detalles sobre las
causas sin embargo se conocía que desde
el año 2011 batallaba contra el cáncer
vamos a Chile porque este miércoles se
registraron protestas en Santiago la
capital contra una nueva ley que
denuncian castiga con mayor severidad a
los crímenes contra la policía un grupo
de estudiantes protagonizaron altercados
contra las fuerzas del orden del país
austral luego de una marcha en rechazo a
dicha Norma el texto se publicó esta
misma semana en la gaceta oficial de la
nación y para amnistía internacional
podría incrementar la impunidad y los
abusos por parte de las autoridades
el expresidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump demandó a su ex abogado Michael
cohen por daños a su reputación por una
suma de más de 500 millones de dólares
la demanda presentada en Miami carga
contra cohen por haber roto asegura un
acuerdo de confidencialidad jóvenes un
testigo estrella en el caso que Avanza
en Nueva York contra Trump por
presuntamente haber falsificado
documentación para encubrir unos
presuntos sobornos a la actriz porno
storminos esto en la campaña
presidencial de 2016 el Antiguo
mandatario se convirtió en el primer
expresidente de la historia del país en
enfrentar cargos criminales de los que
se declaró No culpable ante la Corte
seguimos hablando de Estados Unidos en
donde el miembro de la cámara de
representantes de el estado de Tennessee
pearson fue también reintegrado a su
cargo luego de que el legisladores en
republicanos lo expulsaran por
participar en una manifestación en
contra de la legislación de armas en el
país pearson es el segundo representante
en ser restaurado en su cargo esta misma
semana el informe lo tiene Andrés
triviño
Justin pearson celebró una victoria el
miembro demócrata de la cámara de
representantes del estado de Tennessee
fue reintegrado a su cargo luego de que
en una inusual acción La mayoría
republicana lo expulsara a él y a su
colega Justin Jones
esto es un mensaje para la gente de
Nashville que decidió expulsarnos no
puedes expulsar la esperanza no se puede
expulsar la justicia ni nuestra voz no
Pueden expulsar nuestra lucha nosotros
por supuesto Seguiremos con nuestra
lucha hasta que fluya como agua volvamos
al trabajo
los representantes demócratas fueron
retirados de sus cargos luego de que
encabezaran una protesta por la
legislación de armas en Estados Unidos
motivados por un sangriento tiroteo en
una escuela de Nashville el pasado 27 de
marzo en el cual una persona
diagnosticada con desorden emocional
poseía armas legalmente y dejó un saldo
de tres niños y tres adultos muertos
este tipo de expulsiones son poco
comunes siendo la tercera vez que se
presenta desde la guerra civil de
Estados Unidos una acción condenada por
la Casa Blanca Incluyendo a kamala
Harris quien realizó una visita la
semana pasada para demostrar su apoyo a
los legisladores
ellos optaron por tomar la iniciativa y
Mostrar valentía al decir que una
democracia crea espacios donde la voz
del pueblo se escucha se honra y se
respeta
y entendieron la importancia estos tres
de ponerse de pie y decir que el pueblo
no será silenciado
los demócratas en el senado de Estados
Unidos han pedido al departamento de
Justicia que investigue si se violaron
los derechos constitucionales de los
legisladores expulsados
la mayor empresa de vapeadores acordó
pagar 462 millones de dólares a los
estados de Nueva York California
Illinois Massachusetts Nuevo México y
Colorado y también al distrito de
Colombia para resolver los cargos por
haber violado numerosas leyes en la
comercialización de productos de tabaco
para jóvenes antes ya había acordado
pagar una suma similar a otros 34
estados las autoridades creen que el uso
de cigarrillos electrónicos entre
estudiantes de secundaria y preparatoria
se duplicó con creces después de que
esta marca se introdujera por primera
vez en 2015
a los consumidores sobre el riesgo para
la salud de sus productos la compañía de
cigarrillos electrónicos les hizo creer
falsamente que sus vaporizadores eran
más seguros que los cigarrillos y
contenían menos nicotina sin embargo
sobre una cápsula de Yule contiene tanta
nicotina como un paquete completo de
cigarrillos
terminamos esta emisión informativa al
ritmo de música urbana porque la
biblioteca del Congreso de Estados
Unidos dio a conocer la lista de los 25
nuevos títulos que ingresen en su
registro sonoro y por primera vez figura
una canción de reggaeton
[Música]
se trata de la gasolina el clásico del
puertorriqueño
Daddy Yankee con el que irrumpió en la
escena musical internacional en el año
2004 de la mano de su álbum Barrio fino
la biblioteca destaca que fue esa
canción La que llevó el género a unas
audiencias más grandes consiguiendo
incluso que algunas emisoras
anglosajonas cambiaran sus formatos a
español
con música despedimos hacer misión
informativa la invitación es a ustedes
para que continúen aquí en France 24
[Música]